ich habe dieser tage ein foto gesehen
von
grinse backe oliver pocher der war in
katar und hat sich dort mit einer
deutschlandfahne und einer ein bisschen
kleinen regenbogen armbinde ablichten
lassen ja toll ein ganz mutig also
peinlicher gratis mit peinlicher geht's
eigentlich schon nicht mehr
man muss sich einfach klarmachen dieses
land hat
gastarbeiter die unter klaren
bedingungen gehalten werden müssen ihre
pässe abgeben es gibt ein cover system
wo der wo der arbeitgeber entscheiden
können wie lange er arbeitet wie werden
schlecht bezahlt
6500 bis 15.000 da gehen die schätzungen
auseinander sind gestorben weil die
bedingungen so schlimm sind es gibt
keine pressefreiheit es gibt ein neues
orthodoxen islam religionsfreiheit ist
ein fremdwort es gibt strafen von
auspeitschen bis erschießen es gibt
natürlich keine keine meinungsfreiheit
sondern es herrscht in feudaler manier
eine eine
einzelplatz regierung die auch nicht
abwählbar ist frauenrechte sind im
prinzip ein fremdwort frauen müssen von
ihren männern unterschrieben bekommen
wenn sie auslandsstipendien antreten
wollen wenn sie verträge schließen da
ist dass das mittelalter noch
eine feine sache dagegen man kann
verurteilt werden wegen ungehorsams
wegen ehebruch wegen alkoholkonsum in
der öffentlichkeit als muslim wir haben
ein düsteres unrechtsregimen hinter
zugegebenermaßen glänzenden fassaden und
dann stellt sich herr pocher hin und
feiert sich für den mut dort einen
regenbogen binde getragen zu haben
dieses land geht unter der knute und da
wir übertragen dann einfach unsere
konflikte dahin es geht nicht um ein
paar lesben schwulen oder oder
transsexuelle es geht darum dass ein
ganzes regime dort wirklich
menschenrechte mit füßen tritt und das
ist einfach eine verniedlichung wenn man
sich solche späßchen erlaubt und ich
kann einfach nur sagen augen auf münder
auf das ganze ansprechen und nicht
solche scherz aktionen und so tun als
wäre man jetzt der mut bolzen der nation
frau kalb an klick auf die fußball wm
sollte die regierung auf eine teilnahme
verzichten ja absolut also ich glaube
das kann man auch niemandem erklären
wenn die regierung dort vor ort bei den
menschenrechtsverletzungen die dort
stattfinden und wir uns ja gerade
erwähnt wie mit frauen vor allem dort
umgegangen wird ich glaube wir würden
uns viel viel mehr schaden und ich weiß
nicht wer spaß daran hat da hinzufliegen
sich das da vor ort anzuschauen weil man
weiß wie eigentlich dort die lage vor
ort ist der wirtschaftsminister robert
habeck hat ja auch mit katar verhandelt
wir erinnern uns alle an die fotos da
entstand natürlich schon der eindruck
dass deutschland und katar jetzt auf dem
weg sind ziemlich beste freunde zu
werden das glaube ich gar nicht hat ja
auch gesagt er macht das also
interviewte er auch gesagt dass er das
auch nicht findet dass er jetzt eine
ganz andere eine videobotschaft kind
habe da eine andere sprache gesprochen
und es hat übrigens nichts gebracht also
nicht auf einen einbruch in die jahre
gekommen und die berechenbaren die
bilder nicht fast schlimmer als signal
für die welt als wenn er jetzt dahin
fliegen würde zum fußballspiel nein das
glaube ich nicht weil man zum
fußballspiel hinfliegt und sich dort
sage ich man seine freizeit irgendwie
bewegt uns spaß dort verortet ist was
anderes als wenn ich vor ort hingehe und
versuche für mein land etwas zu
erreichen also dass schon zwei
unterschiedlich gestaltete machen ja
teilnahme fußball wm keine geschäfte
machen ja man hat der gesetz her gar
kein geschäft entstanden so und da sieht
man auch dass geschäfte machen ja mit
der ganzen region main katar ist eine
islamistische diktatur kann man einfach
mal so mit diesem begriff umschreiben
und ich meine ich sagte ja gar nicht
dass wir jetzt nur mit lupenreinen
demokratien handel training dabei
reichlich
aber es zeigt eben wieder mal die völlig
doppelte maßstäbe mit den wie reagieren
und ich fahren wirklich auch damals also
ich finde auch dieses peinlich was sie
angesprochen haben aber ich fand
wirklich diese arbeit besucher natürlich
auch super peinlich als er ist ja nicht
nur hin gefahren sondern hat auch noch
einen bückling gemacht würde ich also
wirklich
glaube ja ja die waage und ich finde
also natürlich finde ich auch dass die
bundesregierung nicht hinfahren sollte
aber es ist eben einfach diese
unehrlichkeit ich mein kater ist ja
nicht nur ein unterdrücker system auch
gegenüber frauen und und opposition die
haben auch jahrelang im jemen mit saudi
arabien zusammen den krieg geführt als
er kriegt läuft immer noch katar macht
zurzeit nicht mit aber haben wir damals
irgendwie gesagt so jetzt müssen wir
unsere wirtschaftlichen verbindungen
kappen jetzt müssen wir unsere geschäfte
beenden wenn ich habe mir nie die haben
ja auch geschäfte mit saudi arabien die
immer noch dort bomberg also wie gesagt
das sind schlimme diktaturen die
wirklich auch für die menschen in diesen
ländern zumindest sofern sie ein
bisschen oppositionelle sind oder auch
nur weiblich oder homosexuell eine
katastrophe sind es sind länder diesen
außenpolitisch aggressiv sind auch für
kriegsverbrechen verantwortlich und
trotzdem macht man da business jude dass
sie würden sanktionen befürworten oder
wie würden sie irgendwie vorgehen ich
glaube nicht dass wir uns einen gefallen
tun wenn wir jedes land dessen beginn
wir ablehnen und zwar aus guten gründen
mit sanktionen belegten mit wem machen
wir da noch handeln der eu handeln sie
sind damit einverstanden dass man mit
saudi arabien und katar handelt wenn es
notwendig ist ich finde dass wir klar
ansprechen müssen wir unsere haltung zu
den regimen ist aber wir haben
geschäftsbeziehungen man muss gucken
wenn man die wenn man bessere
möglichkeiten hat immer aber wir können
jetzt nicht jedes land mit sanktionen
belegen dass solche politischen systeme
hat also das geht also ich meine danke
was mich daran was stört ist dass solche
aktionen einfach das problem
verniedlichen in dem man so tut die ich
habe ja eine binde ich hab mal kurz es
steht deutschland hinter oliver pocher
die hauen ihnen immer raus wenn er
wirklich festgenommen werden sollte vor
der wm wird auch katar kein interesse
daran haben ihn irgendwie einzusperren
oder große wellen zu schlagen also das
ist echt gratis mut von der kleinsten
münze und sowas bringt niemanden weiter
und sowas kann man sich sparen dann soll
er einfach mal ein ernsthaftes gespräch
mit ein paar unterdrückten frauen führen
die da im knast sitzen da sind etliche
journalisten eingesperrt da hätte er
mehr und vielleicht auch ohne
öffentlichkeit da hat er mir hätte er
mehr bewirkt als mit solchen spaß
aktionen